main review they review meme review
YouTube's favorite show ever
last week we hit trending thank you guys
so much for all the support oh boy do we
have a lot of spicy memes for this
week's meme review last week we reviewed
petting dog meme
haha I'm petting a dog and it's many
predecessors you guys posted some as
well you joined in on the meme hi doggie
hey look it's me
Zootopia meme or so topia pro-life meme
or Zootopia I will survive another bribe
karmic meme have you watched Zootopia me
neither but it was about a bunny and a
fox and someone said to themselves hey
I'm gonna I'm gonna make my own version
a comic of that store Disney story about
the Fox and the bunny talking about
complex relationship issues such as
pregnancy and whether you should have an
abortion or not now this meme got a lot
of attention mainly for the fact of the
absorbent absurd absurdity absorbent
absorbedly absurdity for three different
reasons number one Zootopia number two a
bunny and a fox [ __ ] number three the
extremely over-exaggerated panels the
emotions that they've the art is really
captured in this fan fiction it's quite
something so you can easily just replace
the text with pretty much anything and
it will just feel off I cannot live
another day without air conditioning it
says tomorrow's gonna be hotter good
mean they both weigh the same Nick they
are both a kilogram but steel is heavier
than feathers affectionate true I don't
see how people struggle with this mind
thought prog thing steel is heavier than
feathers everyone knows that
because he has this bigger density you
know traps are gay
look I posted this one look at that
everybody I am funny and relevant I post
I post relevant memes please validate me
please we have the one punch man we have
the silly rabbit tricks are for kids
everyone knows that we have there
everything that we know and love is
reducible to the observe acts of
chemicals and there is therefore no in
street sick value in this material
universe hypocrite that you are for you
to trust the chemicals in your brain to
tell you they are chemicals all
knowledge is ultimately based on that
which we cannot prove will you fight or
will you perish like a dog this of
course is based on the Donald Duck meme
and Mickey Mouse meme but it begs really
the question you know people look at
love as some sort of strange substance
that we can't understand when really you
can just break it down in scientific
thing you know what they say love is
blind I don't understand this is this
one is probably my favorite I don't
understand our family our entire clan
why did you kill our parents to measure
my abilities good old Naruto mean it's
over Anakin I have the high ground you
underestimate my power Nick subs not
dubs no I can't believe you just said
that Nick hear me out
really the the numerous amount of comic
strips that can be adapted in this comic
I think is what really makes it so
successful hey how do you sprint
alt f4 clear Nick has left the game
disconnected by user you know I had to
do it to them so dumb hey look it's the
lost meme everybody that's how you truly
know if a meme has been accepted or not
there should have a lost meme then it's
not a true mean we have of course
petting dog meme fans of this common
notice himself that in the very first
image the building is the same building
as the Seinfeld building this begs the
question what's the artist memeing all
along it's a very interesting topic now
I will have to raid it not too high it
was amusing for a while but I think I
think the adaptations so far that I've
seen doesn't really live up to the
potential of this me I mean look at
these facial expressions subs not dubs
can we talk about more important issues
such as Beauty pipe doesn't make
original content so I'm gonna give it a
4.5 I think it can grow to a 5.5 if we
see some better adaptations in the
future and not this sub-genre of memes
like you know I had to do a tomb or Moss
you know and petting dog the meme
there's so much potential that it
doesn't really need to rely on other
memes or crossover memes to live up to
it I think with with clever adaptations
made by the community we can really lift
his meme up and make it stronger
together ice are collected moving on to
the next name this is my favorite meme
of the week which of course is the Doki
Doki literature club memes if you
haven't played okie dokie click away now
not because I don't want to spoil Doki
Doki to you but because Doki Doki
literature Club memes it's something
that you have to work for okay it's a
Normie proof meme it's protected from
normies because you have to sit through
literally two hours of dialogue just to
get to the scary part the people that
can laugh at the Doki Doki memes are the
people that worked hard for the Doki
Doki means we've earned these [ __ ] okay
we work for them
and really that's what all memes are
really it's a it's a secret Club of haha
inside jokes haha that's funny
I know what that originates from I bet
my mom doesn't
ha this mean makes me laugh now ha ha
now doki-doki of course was the game
that looks cute on the outside but on
the inside it's the complete opposite
what I played what I expected what I've
got can you say fictional characters I
gotta tell you this is pretty terrific
now I think what's so great about Doki
Doki means is that each of the four
character Natsuki say Yuri Yuri and
Monica they all have their own
individual subset of memes within the
Doki Doki memes and and and all the
subsets are based on their personalities
and their person and their parent
impersonal events that happen in Doki
Doki
we have Natsu key which is the cute tiny
little girl I mean look at that she's
adorable then you have swole tsuki to
contrast this young tiny little woman I
just want to say for my own personal
record whoever made buff tsuki or or
swallow tsuki you need to die you need
to die and go to heaven straight away it
is god-awful and I don't ever want to
see it the more I look at it the more
the more life gets sucked out of it I
think it's a cursed image and I think
whoever is making it sucks the life out
of people and in an attempt to live
forever
Natsuki square up thought Natsuki which
also is the little edgy character she
saw she's the Sundari of the group we
have her saying her classic her classic
line be careful or you might cut
yourself on that age
moving on we have Sai Ori the main
character of doki-doki
the extremely cute and childish sort of
character which is really the pinnacle
of this meme you gotta say when your
childhood friend rejects your confession
guess I'll die Sayuri forces a smile
through an incredibly pained expression
there were another stock image mean of
the I want to die smile face mean which
makes sense of course because I Yuri
commit suicide Monica this is not a meme
this is just a picture from the game but
reading in after you finish the game it
becomes a meme you kind of left her
hanging this money you know every half
say Yuri dabbing petting dog means here
we have a PewDiePie crossover so you're
a suicide meme we have memes about
happiness goals and generic content
which makes you laugh
ironic memes and edgy means sad and
crippling depression memes everybody
isn't that great
photographer takes a picture of students
before and after telling them I love you
we have Yuri which is cute she's just
timid Monica gets happy Natsuki of
course it's not tsuki and says you can't
damn it
well that's all the Christmas
decorations up only one more thing to
hang she's so cute
which really elevates this meme so much
because of the Japanese influence that
this actually Western game has we have
of cord that blend s version of this
meme
suicide then we have my girl my BAE if
you pick any other girl but Yuri I'm
sorry to say you are reading that's not
being me being offensive or hyperbolic
it's just straight-up facts Yuri is the
number one girl and if you don't realize
that then I have no other choice but to
say there must be something wrong with
you oh look how cute
manga is literature oh no it's returned
we have URI which personal trait is the
the fanatics of the knives so we have of
course the moe mean I gotta tell you
this is pretty terrific I don't know why
this exists I don't stop posting the
[ __ ] monkey haircut memes this is my
favorite meme out of probably all
doki-doki mean because madfinger we have
the two-finger we have the pen and we
have the it's a very subtle meme it's a
very subtle meme and I think a lot of
you probably think you know what the me
miss but you don't really unless you
played okie dokie that's right mom you
don't understand this meme go just click
away from the video this is not for you
mom but last but not least we have the
Monica memes just Monica and the Monica
memes are probably the greatest let's
have a look
[Music]
so you're his [ __ ] wife just Monica well
done I wrote a blog post about job about
why you hate video games because this is
what it does it appeals like the male
fantasy and like how much times
designers probably put into like just
Monica just Monica now there are so many
Monica memes and in Sweden in Sweden we
have a song I mention it in my Doki Doki
playthrough and it's probably one of the
greatest songs ever written it basically
just goes hey Monica hello hey on you
Monica
hey Monica hello on you Monica hey
Monica hello on you Monica
over and over and over this song makes
gucci gang seems seem like a lyrical
genius okay but the scent this song is
so [ __ ] catchy and since we have so
many Monica means I just thought will
disperse the Monica means over this hey
Monica song which should have been just
Monica just just Monica
[Music]
Hey
hey buddy
[Applause]
Hey
[Music]
hey hey I'm gonna aerate it a 7.5
explosion please the highest we've ever
rated the doki doki me I mean any meme
so far if anyone wants to make a website
with a scoreboard what other people can
notice well that would be great
depression undertones which always gives
extra points because of its adaptability
because of its normal protection the
cuteness contrast that it has the
multiple characters of this meme it's a
very strong very strong me last me it's
the Deaf stranding means which I know
what you're saying Felix that's really
not much of a meme and I agree 100%
legendary game maker Kojima is making
finally his own game without Konami and
Sony basically could just open the
floodgates and said hey you know what
you can take how much money you want and
do whatever the heck you want and that
is basically resulted in one of the
weirdest videos I have ever seen people
try and break down what the heck they
just saw in this trailer and what the
game is about and it turns out not even
the people working on the game it has
any idea what the game is about no not
no one knows what the meme is about here
you have the end animator saying again I
thought he was kidding but I soon
realized that Kojima was serious
kijima you are safe now my sweet chat
whatever the hell that was me I owe you
my life
the trailer has so much information on
in it and there's just too much to break
down and we have a lot of questions on
the previous trailer but now we have
even more questions what in the world is
happening why is Norman Reedus having a
baby inside his belly is he going to
give birth to baby
how did baby ended up inside Norman and
which hole will baby come out of these
are the questions that fans are waiting
for and I think I think there's meme the
reason why I'm bringing up this meme is
mainly due to the fact that get on board
now okay
get on board on the memes now because
this is just the beginning of what
clearly if they pan out to be even more
beautiful memes in the future as we go
further along
[Music]
now I don't know about you but I think
the video is pretty straightforward okay
you have these other world creatures
that wants to kill the people right so
they have the baby and he's like ah [ __ ]
I've been discovered he throws away the
baby as soon as he realized he's been
just discovered and tried to kill
himself but he fails in the trailer you
can see people aging faster while being
in this black gooey thickness or
whatever I think the baby is basically
you moving your soul into the baby which
is why is doing the thumbs up just like
the guy did and the trailer before he
died and then the goo is used to age
himself quicker does that make sense of
course it does of course it does this
mean I'm giving a three but it has a
long yeah so much potential that this
could be a 7.5 just like doki-doki so
I'm urging you get on board now and that
was it for this week of MAME review I
want to thank all my family all my
friends all my fans and all my dogs
thank you guys so much for another
episode let's get this on trending MAME
review everybody meme review and escort
them
Hey
[Applause]